I'm an accent I've got a baby come here
tell me so we just had the email through
Her Royal Highness the Duchess of
Cambridge was safely delivered of a
daughter 834 this morning the baby
weighs 8 pounds three ounces
the Duke Cambridge was present for the
birth Oh got a need to breathe the Queen
the Duke of Edinburgh the Prince of
Wales the Duchess of Cornwall Prince
Harry who's in Australia a members of
both families have been informed and are
delighted with the news Her Royal
Highness and her child doing well be a
princess and share it with the family so
it's a girl let's go this way
ain't patrie you knew when you weren't
telling me this way to go it's a girl
it is a girl that's okay just a short
while ago